the CDC says older adults and people
with chronic medical conditions are most
at risk for the corona virus we've got
our doctor Taryn Rula here to explain
what precautions to take if you or your
loved ones are vulnerable so we keep
talking about people who are vulnerable
what does that mean in practice what
conditions are most susceptible to the
virus right so on the CDC call yesterday
that they gave as a briefing they
mentioned these conditions
cardiovascular disease including things
like hypertension diabetes if you have
chronic lung disease but also if your
immunosuppressed you have cancer some
you're on some medication that is
weakening your immune system these are
some of the conditions that we're
talking about we're familiar we're
talking about things that affect the
young and the old and usually those
populations are both phone or mobile
right we have the old vulnerable but
children apparently not why it's so
interesting so you're right you usually
see a u-shaped curve where at the tips
of your you the kids and the elderly
your most vulnerable with covin 19:00
we're really seeing kids being spared
from severe disease and the elderly
being affected when we talk about ages
we're talking about individuals over 60
but with risk really increasing the
older you get over 80 being at the
highest risk why might this be well when
you look at the elderly they tend to
have weaker immune systems they also
have more of these chronic health
conditions and what we think is that
their immune system reaction to the
virus may be kind of dysregulated
overwhelming so they developed what we
call cytokine storm you release all
these inflammatory mediators that then
damage the lungs when you look at the
kids on the other hand what's kind of
reassuring for parents is at least in
China the 70,000 cases they looked at
less than 2% or in those individuals
under the age of 19 no children died in
South Korea or know anybody under 30
there are no deaths and no deaths under
the age of 9 in China again how does
this happening you know kids may have
for some reason the virus may not
replicate as easily they may have less
mature receptors in the lungs we call
the ACE receptors with a virus latches
on - and another theory is that as kids
you're exposed to all these other corona
viruses not Kovan 19 maybe you're
developing antibodies that are cross
reactive alright we're pregnant women
more vulnerable in this another thing
that a lot of women want to know so we
don't have a lot of data on
so it's a data free area what is the
effect on pregnant women on the fetus on
the infant what we know is that during
pregnancy your immune system sort of
down regulates so that you don't reject
the baby and also your physiology
changes and this can set you up for
being more vulnerable to respiratory
viruses when you look at SARS and MERS
we did see some cases where there was
pregnancy loss or miscarriage so far in
a limited case series in China we have
not seen transmission from mother to
baby in the newborns that were looked at
and no evidence of virus in the amniotic
fluid or breast milk
what about smoking and vaping yes how
does that impact well if there was ever
a reason to quit here's another one
right anything that's going to
compromise your lungs is going to
increase your risk of being susceptible
we know that smoking decreases your
ability to really fight infection and
one other interesting thing is that in
China we see more men dying from kovin
19 than women and one of the theories is
that 50% of men in China smoke less than
2% of women smoke this smoke yes so so
the CDC is now actively saying avoid
cruises if you're in this vulnerable
population are there other precautions
that you could say would be wise right
so you saw Stephen Colbert yes so for
vulnerable populations you really do
want to try to stay home avoid
situations where you're going to be in
close contact with other people where
there's a lack of real great ventilation
where you're going to be exposed to the
droplets and even non-essential long
plane flights you want to avoid stock up
on important medications whether it's
blood pressure medicine diabetes meds
fever or pain meds that you might need
supplies avoid high touch surfaces so
handles elevator buttons anything where
you get exposed and then this is really
important is to make a plan with your
caregiver what's going to happen who's
going to take care of me what if my
caregiver gets sick and then also people
don't like to discuss what they might
want to happen in the event that they do
decompensate do I want a breathing tube
put in what is my end-of-life care look
like and that these are hard discussions
but important discussions to have some
tough decisions hopefully people will
begin to think about them
talk about yes thank you dr. taryn
roulade